you had a brief foray into magic is that
correct or my misunderstanding well yes
I mean one of the first times I was ever
on stage was at a magic show it didn't
go very well but uh basically I was I
was going to a very tiny art school in
Pennsylvania called Keystone college and
are you kidding yeah I've been doing
this a long time and that guy's full of
[ __ ] that's one of those I'll watch this
later at the bar and here my clap well
anyway it is a great school and I but I
didn't have a car as a very tiny tiny
school like a thousand kids at the time
and I would always take advantage of any
kind of entertainment that they had come
like you know they would bring in
entertainment you know like a caricature
artist or a hypnotist I was like I was
always there and then one day there was
a magic show and I was like yes like
this is gonna be awesome very excited
about the magic show and I was walking
to lunch and this guy comes up to me
he's like hey you go on a magic show of
course I am and he's like hey I'm
actually the magician would you be able
to help me with a trick and I was like
oh my god I feel like I just got
discovered this is the most amazing
thing and so I was like heck yeah so he
takes me to where the show is going to
be and he's like all you have to do is
sit down like in this box and then lay
down in the table and that's it and so
he shows me what to do it's a metal box
in a metal table I do it no problem easy
great I am stoked I'm gonna be in the
show
so I tell everyone like I go to lunch
and I'm like guys you're not gonna
believe it I'm gonna be in the magic
show like you guys got to come so I get
all of my friends to go and and then
we're sitting there and you know ready
for the show to start and I see the
magician he's like okay good like kind
of what makes up me like yeah you got
this and I'm like I got you man and and
then it comes time for him to go and now
I will pick someone as at random and I
was like oh no I've just told everyone I
know
this guy's whole cover like and he's
pretending like now Lu and I tell anyone
so I was just like oh oh no so I of
course I was not a performer at the time
I was so nervous I start sweating I'm
shaking I'm like I've just ruined this
guy's whole act so I get a picks you all
your friends know like oh okay yeah you
think you should have heard the crowd
like wait a second well you know and so
then I get in there and he's like
alright all you have to do is you know
sit down in the box lay down on the
table
I basically froze I got so scared
I fall into a metal box into the metal
table which that sound is a very unique
you've ever heard a human fall into a
metal box into a metal table it's really
loud yeah and as I went down I sliced my
hand pretty badly oh my god so I'm
laying in the table and he says can he
shuts the bar so he goes are you okay do
you want me to like call like you know
paramedics or something it's not that
bad yeah I might just do the trick to
the trick and I didn't know what the
trick was going to be so anyway he then
closes up the box and then he goes and
now I will put his sword through the box
and another sword and he's like just
putting swords through the box and I'm
listening I'm holy and you're safe
because you're in a secret compartment
yeah it works and I learned something
yeah I just learned something yeah so
I'm holding my bloody hand and then you
know at the end of the trick he goes and
now ladies and gentlemen here she is and
I stand up and blood
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's a murderer yeah it healed okay
you